you know what's crazy bro you knows
crazy I was shot someone out for my
streams her nickname is poison ivy this
is the funniest [ __ ]
so she donated to one of my streams it's
just a small small amount with the
message she was like I was hooking up
with this guy I caught feelings and he
ghosted me what do I do
so I said okay if you want to know my
honest opinion if you want to be like
evil you-you-you [ __ ] his friend okay
but that I'm like but that's like that's
like a that's like zero to 100 I'm like
if you really like want to get in his
head
you hit him up you suck the soul out of
him you give him the sloppy 9000
spin cycle top and you and you ghost him
back yeah so so she does it she's like
she was like a few days later I scream
she's like well it's like guess what I
met up with that guy I put his [ __ ]
through a carwash I haven't hit him up
since and he's just blowing up my phone
no way yeah Wow so uh so you know and I
was joking I was like is what's gonna
happen is you're gonna do that
and then one of his boys and be like
what's up with uh-oh what's her name
he's gonna be ouch rest in peace
yes she like sucked the soul out of my
dick which you know I don't even want
she hasn't hit me back but it's like I
didn't even you know I didn't even I
wasn't I mean I go through her first so
I didn't I didn't care I just you know
but you know so so he's blowing her up
and then a few days later I stream and
she's like oh no that's what it was he's
blowing up he's blowing up her phone and
simultaneously his friend is hitting her
up because I'm like yeah cuz he wanted
told his boy his boys like she did what
and she's not hitting you back I might
have to you said she sucked it out I
might have to look at you dr. Phil so so
so I was like as I said all right now
that this is on you I'm like if you want
to fully be the devil
you'll go [ __ ] his friend that's on you
because he was like alright um [ __ ] it's
red and I'm like
oh my god I don't know I'm waiting to
hear back Jesus Christ
yeah you're like a twisted dr. Phil I'm
evil tries to [ __ ] people's lives out I
just said if you want to get him back
if I was a girl this is what I would do
she's dr. Kiehl yeah I hikes yeah well I
mean you know twitch it's just like she
comes back she's like guess what I
[ __ ] his friend and his dad why didn't
they do that oh come on now and I [ __ ]
his mom too what you've turned me into a
monster no no I didn't I didn't I didn't
I went to the cops I told him if you
told me to do it the cops arrest me
all right no I'll be honest with you
I've been talking this girl for awhile
and I can't get her to text me [ __ ]
friend so this demon chick the way she
gives that does it does she really put
it through a car wash cuz I want to know
I want to know she could be lying to me
but I just feel like to go on Twitch and
to pay money to say it I feel like you
have to be doing it
you know maybe hmm this knows or maybe
it's just a weird you know imagine
that's fine
yeah that's fine I was reading some
pretty funny imagines this morning
imagines yeah look they're like they're
like little fanfics that people do on on
Instagram it's actually really weird
it's like I don't know how far behind I
am on this I don't know it just someone
someone said commenting on something it
was like hey you should do a video but
worst imagines it sounds like searching
imagines on Instagram and trying to
figure it out but it's like basically
people will pote like they'll they'll
fake a text screenshot from a celebrity
okay like it's from your point of view
so like you're getting the text and
you're reading it so you're reading the
conversation as if you're sending the
messages I guess and it's like Harry
Styles and Niall Horan and all that [ __ ]
and they're like
like telling you they miss you but like
all through text but the narratives get
super weird got it like some of them
aren't even sexual it's just like hey
why'd you [ __ ] my friend and like weird
[ __ ] like that
but it's all third text it's so and then
it's like it could be a text with anyone
yeah right like your it looks like the
text messages you get from like an
ex-girlfriend or something people like
hey I miss you like have you been
but then there's just a picture of Niall
Horan half the screen is him oh yeah my
god yeah that makes sense
you're a grown man at work oh my god but
no I just gotta cut I got a text from
from who it's a really we just throw
Niall Horan IOR and I I [ __ ] his
friend his friend and he's all pissed
now he always gets like this he gets
super emotional yeah we have a whole
history I thought you were married oh oh
I am yeah I am you know this is just
it's an imagined a white
it's an imagined I I got the text from
now see that's me and that's Niall
there's a big picture of him in there so
you know being a grown man doing like a
little girl how long guys my uh a little
a fan edit of Harry and it's just it's
too a numbers if I'm being honest it's
popping it's popping it's popping this
has to be that it's one of the top on my
on my edits account oh this is some hot
tea right here yeah this is Harry yes
Harry accent yes wait I want to see if I
can find it a bookmarked a couple of
them oh how do I get to my bookmarks
yeah okay this one this one is from this
one's from this is great this one's from
Shawn Mendes okay and you know because
they're so weird and the name just says
the text is Shawn okay so and this is
you okay so this is POV okay so try and
picture this POV I'm yours the one who
text from Shawn Mendes from Shawn Mendes
he's the one sending you the text
messages and
you're sending them to Shawn Mendes got
it hey Shawn it's been 45 minutes are
you coming the food is getting cold oh
oh sorry I didn't show up I got a little
busy
oh okay dude [ __ ] is that oh that's okay
another time look I want to be honest
[ __ ] Shawn's about to be honest oh you
are a really nice girl but you aren't
really my type of girl oh so I was
looking if you could hook me up with
Sarah ooh okay so this is how you feel
about this you say oh wow this is a lot
to take in I hope you have a great night
all right cut him off kind of give him
the old shoulder a little bit because
who is he asking yeah came up with Sarah
right and they says I don't mean I don't
like you but you ain't just my type okay
so what's up with Sarah and that's the
end that's it's good it's called [ __ ]
boy Shawn who would ever want to imagine
getting played I don't know that's one
saying that's the Internet that's this
further proof the Internet is [ __ ] up
all kinds of concept of proper
relationships that's so great
it's so [ __ ] great
[Music]